let's now speak to the most important
people
involved with the david pakman show
which are the viewers without the
viewers i'm a guy in a room with a
microphone and it's sad and it's
disappointing so we take calls via
discord at
davidpakman.com
discord and today we're going to start
with jonah in las vegas jonah welcome to
the program what's on your mind
hey david just wanted to know your
thoughts on the nevada senate race
that is coming up i'm from there so just
interested to hear your thoughts i
haven't been following it to be honest
what's going on
uh the republican it was trump's number
one big lie
sort of conspirator in the state
um he was attorney general in 2018. oh
adam
that's right yeah and it's one of the
closest senate races by the polls by the
metrics by professionals whatever yeah
what i'm seeing is that uh
catherine cortez masto
um has overtaken black salt in the
latest polls even though he had been
leading is that correct
uh it's been back and forth throughout
the cycle but
um
yeah regardless it's gonna be
uh incredibly close i think biden won by
two percent and she in her initial
election also won by two percent yeah
and the polling actually seems
controversial because there's only two
polls from august one has cortez masto
up seven and one has adam laxalt up
three i am not a fan of adam laxalt i
think he's absolutely horrifying uh and
i support cortez masto there and i think
that's an important race for people to
follow and get involved with you can
phone bank uh we we don't want to give
that one to laxalt
definitely
all right my otherwise vegas is good
yeah i mean
the uh it was really hit very hard by
covid but um
with the service industry but yeah
it's coming back well thanks jonah great
to speak to you
you too all right there is jonah from
vegas with a reminder about a very very
important race that's for sure